congrats first off on season four
congrats on the sag nomination
amazing
well deserved well-deserved thank you so
much that's so kind thank you yeah um
what like what does that feel like for
you guys to i want to say finally
because i'm a fan of the show finally
recognized like that
it's an amazing feeling you know
honestly
uh it was just such an incredible gift
to like be in that room with all those
actors who i admire so much you know
like i mean our cast i admire the actors
in our cast so much and it felt so right
uh to see them alongside all these other
incredible performers from all these
other shows it felt like oh my god my
friends from yellowstone fit right in
amongst all these geniuses so that that
was an incredible gift and then just as
an actor
uh
a rare and unique opportunity to sort of
geek out and meet all these actors who
i've admired for years and years you
know
amazing so amazing all right so season
four
dare i say
jimmy has finally
had his i want to say glow up but
because we're talking about cowboys i'm
gonna say giddy up
that's
great
that's really good you got to trademark
that that's better better
um but he's you know i mean in all
honesty he's sort of figured his life
out in this season and i want to say one
of his storyline was one of like
you know the biggest journeys
so for you as an actor having played him
for four seasons what was that like
emotionally to finally sort of get
you know
i don't even i don't even know what the
word was like i want to say like are you
proud of jimmy because we are
oh that's amazing yeah i mean it's a
fascinating thing you know because i
think we all contain
pre
giddy up jimmy and post giddy up jimmy
you know we're always all of us are
sometimes lost children who need a lot
of guidance who need to be taken care of
and then sometimes we step up and sort
of you know sit a little taller in the
saddle so for me it was yeah it was very
exciting and i was proud of jimmy but it
was also intimidating because
in many ways i feel like
i feel like jimmy in the sense that i'm
still learning so much
i still crave you know leadership craig
people telling me where to go that
that's an easier way for me to move
around the world and so as jimmy sort of
self-actualizes and comes into himself
and takes on more and more
responsibility that's in equal parts
something i'm proud of but also there's
a lot of there's a lot of responsibility
there to live up to so i feel very
um i feel very uh grateful to have been
trusted by taylor and by our creative
team to sort of step into those boots
and also i just i just really want to
live up to it you know so it's also uh
an intimidating task
yeah i want to say as you're talking
about it i like you said everyone sort
of has a little pre and post giddy up
jimmy in them but you know i want to say
that like you i want to say you're kind
of um
you're really like inhabiting like that
same sort of feeling from jimmy because
i felt like that in the season too right
like he really wants to live up to the
experience and the the um you know
journey and you know what they've like
bestowed upon him now right
yeah yeah and i very much want to live
up to that on this set this is a set
that it's a job that i've had for four
years now going into our fifth season
uh everybody's been incredibly patient
with me kind with me they've given me a
lot of time and space to learn to like
step into this world that's new to me
but at a certain point i have to start
taking accountability i have to start
sort of holding my own in this
environment you know and so that that's
my my experience my journey really
mirrors jimmy's in that way
uh and so it really as as jimmy kind of
becomes
a cowboy sort of accepts that
responsibility that also represents me
you know stepping into that
responsibility and uh and living up to
the brand you know
amazing
um now i want to talk about the four
sixes ranch because where we leave jimmy
is that he's
there i have so many questions for you
are we gonna see jimmy in season five of
yellowstone
yeah yeah jimmy will be in season five
of yellowstone there's a lot there's a
lot of uh
a lot of texas to explore
and that's all i really know you know
i'm really excited to go back to work
but to be honest all they've told me is
that i'm going back to work so i'm
really excited anytime i try to guess
what taylor's going to do
i'm wrong and what he comes up with is
so much better than anything i could
have imagined so i'm really excited to
go back to work
i don't exactly know what state i'm
going to i don't exactly know you know
what going back to work entails but i
can't wait i can't wait to get back in
the saddle yeah
does that so does that mean that you
can't tease us anything about four sixes
yet if i knew i would if i knew anything
i'd be honored i'd be honored to tease
it to you but uh
really like i said i mean i'm just
waiting to hear and i'm ready to go
wherever they need me every you know
like
working creative work is such a trust
exercise it's such an exercise in
trusting uh your collaborators
and uh at this point
taylor and the other the you know the
rest of our crew on yellowstone have
have earned that trust to the nth degree
so at this point i'm ready to go
wherever they need me and wherever they
tell me to go and he's told me to do
some weird stuff you know
but you know i trust him so whatever he
needs me to do
i jump into it i jump into it amazing um
and i i want to say that um a lot of
you've gotten a lot you've gotten to
spend a lot of on-screen time with
taylor in season four um
you know what was it like spending time
with the boss
but also what is it like sort of um you
know coming through that relationship
with the two of them i think by the end
of that uh
you know jimmy is aspiring to live up to
travis's uh
you know belief in his potential in the
same way that i jeff i'm trying to live
up to taylor's belief in my potential
you know that's i you know i really look
up to taylor and he's given me
you know the best job i've ever had in
my life so every day i'm sort of trying
to prove that i deserve it and that that
experience of going down and working on
the sixes which was a you know a
splinter unit that left the yellowstone
main crew
uh and taylor taylor directed that unit
and brought us down to texas and so it
really was an opportunity for me to
to try to live up to uh to the the
opportunities he's given me and that the
trust that he's put in me you know
yeah
okay so
we also know
and like i want to take a moment here to
shout out everyone on tick tock who did
not give you the credit that you deserve
when they are sharing those thirst tick
tocks about the yellowstone cast because
jimmy
in season four
had not one
but two relationships
right he left montana with a girlfriend
and came back at the fiance and i feel
like now is the time for all those tick
talkers
to eat their words because
the proof is in the pudding right the
proof is in season four so but my real
question is
but but so the question is what are what
do we have in store and i you know with
with nothing really being set for season
five i'm not sure you can answer this
but what would you love to see for jimmy
and emily
moving ahead in season five
i mean i would love for jimmy to have
some personal agency i think for the
last four seasons it's has been his job
when someone tells him to jump you know
to say how high like that that's been
his job for
for years now so i i hope that he can
make some of his own decisions and make
decisions for the sake of his little
family you know i think that he and
emily represents this this little family
you know for the first time in jimmy's
life i don't think he's ever really had
that so i hope that he can find
you know the strength and the courage to
make decisions
uh for the the benefit of his own little
family and not just get kind of pulled
around
and knocked about by these forces much
larger than him you know one thing that
that mia said
in season three that has really stuck
with me
is she says don't just be another one of
that rich man's cattle you know
and i i guess that's what i hope for
jimmy i hope that jimmy can find a sense
of self and a sense of agency that is
independent of these these
rich men who have been very generous to
him but who also have sought to um
control him and tell him where to go his
whole life you know
absolutely well thank you so much for
chatting with me huge fan of the show so
excited to see where jimmy's gonna go in
season five and where he's gonna oh
thanks kate it's been such a pleasure
thank you so much
you